what do you think is
strengths and weaknesses of Elon Musk uh
you mentioned Twitter have you paid your
eight dollars I have not paid my dollars
I don't see the point in paying for it I
have no problem paying for services I
use a ton of services I'll try the free
I'll go to the paid
um right now so the way I used to use
the verified feed was I would post a
tweet and then the next day when I you
know review what's going on in my social
media I would look at the replies to the
Tweet which would give me a mix of
replies from verified and unverified
people but then I'd also look at the
verified and see who that are
verified public folks have responded to
me or maybe I want to engage with or
whatever the case may be
there's I don't even understand why I
would look at the verified feed anymore
so I never do because it's random folks
who I don't know when it sort of lost
its utility to me and then yeah sorry to
interrupt but the idea is if everybody
who's human pays the eight dollars it
shows to you that it's not Bots it's at
least humans from the reports about the
number of people that have bought the
blue check mark I think we may be a
thousand years from enough signups in
order to make that sort of like a
reality that was the idea it's an
interesting idea honestly
from my experience the obviously I was
seeing all sorts of attack comments some
of which were I'm sure from Bots but I'm
ignoring all of those comments anyway so
it really didn't affect my my experience
that much I mean here's the thing about
Elon and I say this people sometimes
like David you you obviously hate Elon
or you obviously love Elon
I was an investor in Tesla starting in
2015. I've since sold all my shares
great run
um I'm on my second Tesla right now
I probably won't get a third one because
I think that electric vehicle technology
is now maturing such that when my lease
is up I'm gonna have many more options
with the range and charging Network
that's important to me but I could be
wrong maybe you know I don't know I have
no the Cults of personality around
people they mean nothing to me so for me
it's just like people are people nobody
has only good ideas fine I think that
what Elon Musk did accelerating and
pushing forward the battery and electric
vehicle technology is unbelievable it's
it's a it's a one person
wrecking ball in the best sense of
saying we're not going to slow play this
and do okay now Toyota has a Toyota
hasn't actually entered but now whoever
we've got a 90 mile range car and next
year it'll be 110 and it's just like
we're doing this right now you can
compete or you can opt out and look at
what's happened fantastic
on the Twitter side of things I don't
really get the whole plan I don't know
if it started maybe as kind of a goof of
some kind and it developed into I guess
I have to buy it and I think something
about it ended up with there was a
clause invoked where I think he did try
to get out of buying it but then was
forced due to some degree yeah he was
forced the way Twitter used to work was
you followed people
and when you looked at your feed you
either saw the posts from the people you
were following in Reverse chronological
order or posts from the people you
followed algorithmically tailored to
what you're most likely to want to see
and if
you didn't follow someone you generally
wouldn't see their posts unless it was
like a sponsored tweet or someone you
follow quoted or retweeted them fine the
for you feed Tick Tock I believe First
had a so-called for you feed the idea is
this is stuff you might like based on I
don't know what either demographic data
about you your other habits whatever and
so it's useless to me it's just it's
just basically mostly right-wing content
that that is not interesting why do you
think that is I mean so uh the the
signals that are used to generate the
for you page is looking at all your uh
likes all your comments all your uh
blocks and mutes and all that so that I
mean I don't know what it's looking at
okay so it's supposed to be very
pleasant for you I'm sure other people
go wow this for you thing is awesome and
I'll get like if you had
insert some right wing or sitting here
there we go Twitter used to suppress
right-wing voices and now finally
they're getting the fair shake that they
deserve in the for you feed okay I mean
I wonder if there's a left-wing folks
uh setting their feelings of you on a
side that are enjoying the for you page
that's a really important question
because it's supposed to be people on
the left-hand people on the right should
be enjoying the for you page sure yeah I
mean so for me my thought on Elon is
some incredible successes
I don't know about Twitter I do think
that I I don't believe Elon is a right
winger and when you see interviews with
him
um certainly at least socially and in
many ways culturally seems very moderate
or even somewhat on the left in my
experience or I don't think it's elon's
a right winger I don't that's not an
interesting critique it does seem though
that throughout the Twitter Escapade he
certainly ended up closer
to some voices that may be influencing
him in a particular way uh that's giving
some people that impression you know but
as far as like the Elon hate or the Elon
love it's just it's just a person who's
done some interesting things some of
which I like and some of which I could
kind of leave leave aside